thank you Yasser we are indeed with a
very special guest the 13th world
champion and The Mastermind behind
granchester the one and only Gary
Kasparov Gary welcome to the show
Welcome to our renewed Studio here in
Bucharest this is the fourth year we
come here in Bucharest every single year
it seems like the organization steps one
notch above do you feel the same way
absolutely absolutely and today I spoke
with Augusta dragic she's in charge of
the organization and she was still you
know complaining that nothing was
perfect you know I said look we'll stay
if everything it was perfect now what
would you do next year so let's see
always in room for improvement but as I
mentioned in my in my remarks at the
opening ceremony it's just it's it's
phenomenal event and and you could just
you can appreciate the uh um the
attention paid to every detail by the
organizers and again immense respect
that the game of chess receives uh here
in Bucharest of course we know it's
Saint Louis that's the that set up
standards but in Europe I can I can
hardly recall you know the same
um Devotion to to the game of chess and
to chess players and you can actually
see the the face of the chess players
you know they did I think they were
thrilled you know so this is it's this
is again a moment I've been dreaming
about for so many years when I was on
the professional chess Arena that we
reached a point where chess will be
treated with this respect and this honor
will be given to the game and the chess
players from both as Atlantic and I have
to say yesterday during the opening
ceremony first of all there were no
seats open absolutely uh and the opening
ceremony was Pat I like it was being in
television it's the you know it's it's
it's really the moment where we could
see that the game of chess is spreading
because it was so many years again we
heard this complaints ah just was so
popular on Fisher plates basket when uh
kaspora played carpool when just you
know it's a long time ago
um and I think people missed missed
these the the dramatic increase in in
numbers in the Wall of China the
following
that kept growing but it was not on the
front page this was not on on Main
television news
um and I think now we see that that how
all these changes you know on the ground
changes they have been uh translated
into uh into Big Splash so we we have
attention uh and also we we can we can
brag about about achieving success it
bows in America and in Europe so Italy
now uh God this is the I think the the
most powerful uh most impressive network
of of Chess tournaments uh Bucharest
warsaws
that's ever had maybe again it's a long
long time ago but now it's um it's so
spectacular or the events are glamorous
and the wild Bucharest is sitting at
standards but we also
are about to see the impressive event in
Warsaw and of course that group there
must be something about having the new
world champion as well as the Challenger
one when we finish the world
championship match how did that came
about and how do you feel about how do
you see their energy and Aura as well
look up
it's as we discussed just briefly
briefly before the interview that's it's
the first time where the world champion
plays in Romania yeah because macros
never played here so that's why of
course Rubina Romanians are thrilled and
they knew in advance they would be a
world champion one way or another
whatever whatever uh would be the
outcome of matching a in in astronauts
so it will end up with a wall champion
and the runner-up playing uh in uh in in
Bucharest including Also let's not
forget the winner of the previous
branches to uh yeah so
um and um I think that is just my
impression but I think ding still
doesn't believe he's a world champion
because the moment you say world
champion I think he looks around
yeah it's yeah it's it's interesting
Dynamics but um but I think it's again
it's important we move forward and uh
and uh while again I think everybody
myself included were disappointed by
Magnus decision but it's his call and uh
and again life doesn't end and um and I
think the fact is that we have all the
best players Magnus will join also the
tour in in in
group uh so it's it's we'll make it make
this year branches tour the most
representative one so it's the it's a
really you know professional chess
Network established uh over years uh
that has every professional component uh
uh
from every organization of detail to you
know a whole um
um suspense of the event because it's we
we always try to build it
um to keep the the momentum not
disappearing until the very very uh uh
last game in Saint Louis and and I could
tell you that this is with this kind of
success the branches 2 will grow uh
again I don't know what are the plans on
the other side what feed is going to do
but but we are very comfortable we have
strong sponsors
um uh growing interest and I I would
think about expanding ranchers tool to
you to Western Europe uh next year you
mentioned that thing might actually be
incredulous about being the world
champion how did you feel the first
couple of weeks after becoming a world
champion yourself
uh was there an adjustment period okay
yes it's a uh yeah maybe not so much
because look I I became world champion
in 1995 playing second match with scorp
so what I I I already had so much time
to to to
fantasize about this moment because I
played a long match with carpool you
know I played candidates so many things
happened almost by Miracle so Magnus
dropped then let's remember the last
game you know in in candidates he beat
Nakamura again there was another miracle
so it's the uh I mean Hikaru all he
needed the draw and and the game was so
druish so again this is the Stars you
know all the work for dig and how many
times during this match against nepo
dink probably does okay that's horror it
was it could be over so many times so
this is and eventually everything worked
for him and I think he's still you know
he's he has to digest it and that's
that's look it's uh
they're very bad after Magnus he has
very big shoes to to feed him and uh um
I think he understands his
responsibility uh he's not yet ready for
that but look that's something that you
have to you have to live with and but by
the way I can tell you it's not just
about me but um I I realized I was a
world champion just almost instantly but
but many people you know just around me
they still thought about carpool against
psychological so many years so it's
again everything takes time and the
narrow again the thing is in a very odd
situation because yes he is the world
champion this undoubtedly he's a 17th
world champion it's legally just you
know followed all all the rules and
procedures that's why I I always said
that you couldn't compare it to 1993
moment it's more like 1975 moment but
Fisher left carpool was you know the
world champion and and uh he was the
dominant player he quickly established
his domination dink has to perform at a
time where there are many competing
forces and you have Napoli CE or Fabi is
here and also alireza and you still have
Madness
Mrs is there you know so so that's that
great that creates a very new momentum
for the game of chess which again
fantastic as as someone who's watching
the event so I'm
I'm really happy that we have this new
uh new Intrigue Gary it's an honor as
always to have you in the studio you
will be here for a few days
yes first for Rounds so when I'm just uh
let's see what happens in in in the
first round I understand now we have the
delay yes we try to we try to cheat the
cheaters Yes
okay thank you